yo what's up it's nelly choppa checking
me out on the bootleg calf podcast let's
get it you know what it is
boulet cavs show special guest here uh
my guy and ali choppa man know what it
is we're back here yeah the new album is
uh well by the time this comes out it'll
be out
um
first of all yeah what are you drinking
cmos
with spring water
shasta um
the sea moss came from honduras
fun fact it came from the same place
that um
dr sebi used to get a lot of hissy mush
from
same
dive so help me understand i mean i do
cmos but i take pills right they're
probably crunched up you said that
that's not good for you yeah it's not
good because the capsules they weaken
the immune system because what they're
made of out of you know some of them
made out of plastic right another thing
so on what it does is temporarily it
works but over the time it's hard to you
know get um get the plastic and stuff
out of the way
so we're breaking down so
you
this is raw cmos you just put it in the
water and this is your this is your
drink yeah the wasabi mozzarella yeah is
it is it good is it terrible
i'm used to it now you know whatever i
feel like whatever is good for me i'm
cool with consuming i ain't really
looking for the taste of it i'm just
looking for the benefits you know um
you i'd like to point i do think that
the first time that people really got to
get a real glance of
where you were at on your health [ __ ] on
your
as they call you enely chakra
yeah i feel like that was when you came
on my show in 2020. yeah um
talk about just like uh you know how how
do you feel now that you're like fully
you know it's been what a year and some
change since you've been living this
lifestyle how are you feeling
honestly i feel i feel the best i've
ever felt just knowing my purpose just
knowing what i'm here for and i'm saying
knowing that i'm here to impact people
lives deeper than just making music or a
song i feel like i feel like you know
i'm just happy as i ever been because i
know why i'm here i know me i know
myself yeah so are you like noticing
that like your fans or people who follow
you are starting to try to implement
some more health [ __ ] into their life
hey a lot of people you know my peers my
family um every time i interview with
interview have an interview with
somebody something they take away that
they hit me back or they'll find someone
to reach out and be like oh i took this
from you i've been doing this you know
so i feel like just me being vocal about
what i go through every day is like it
helps trying to work help people around
you know it's crazy because uh i think
the first time we met we were talking
and i was like dude
you're super talented you got a good
head on your shoulders i think i met you
with your parents yeah the radio station
this is right when your ig got taken
away yo on me might have been the same
day i was high as hell today yeah um
and i was like man you know
you're always up involved in some
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet right
and
i feel like you've matured so much over
the last couple of years
um and i feel like mentally you're in a
space where a lot of artists just aren't
right a lot of your peers aren't really
where you are um but it feels like
people are just trying to always drag
you drag you back into old nle yeah or
just into some [ __ ] [ __ ] like
is it hard to not
you know
kind of get back into that mind state
you know what i mean i feel like
at the end of the day whatever i was in
the past is still a part of me so
it's never like it's never like you grow
so much it's not there no more you know
it's still a part of me so certain
people might get that type of reaction
they looking for out of me you know
because at the end of the day i've grown
and i mature but at the end of the day
at heart and then so i'm the same person
i'm just more mature than i know how to
balance it like when to be this person
and when to be that i'm saying so if i'm
protecting my name my brand my family my
daughter my son whatever i am that
person that they once knew me for
because at the end of the day i kill for
my family i do whatever i got to do for
anybody around me that i love or
anything that i love of course but it's
just about being having a balance of it
you know because at the end of the day
it's going to come with with you being
good with you being on what you're doing
what you trying to be positive and i'm
saying that [ __ ] going to come
negativity haters it's going to come
because it's just the devil working
overtime trying to knock you off your
pivot yeah and then i also just feel
like
you know like
what the uh
explain to me is there is there like i
i'm assuming you don't have any issues
with young boy it feels like he's just
got issues with everyone no i ain't got
issues with nobody you know
i mean type type lifestyle i live it's
there's no room for that i'm saying i'm
focused on too much to be be able to
empower what i got going to be able to
empower my family to be able to empower
myself like this this this little kid
stuff you know that's fifth grade stuff
to me now i'm saying we on bigger better
things i'm trying to change the world i
got no problem with nobody the beef
comes from the mind the beef and the
enemy is the mind whatever i move and
pride you know what i'm saying that's
what it is so
that's some real [ __ ] um
you push back your album a week uh
dolphin and and uh you know obviously
everyone who signed the dolph put out
the long lived golf project out of
respect to dolph
you guys are from the same city
um
what was your guys's relationship like
i'm not saying i'm like i've seen them
two times but it wasn't never
a relationship that was just built like
you know i could call on him right call
on me but at the end of the day was
mutual respect you know always it wasn't
ever anything but at the end of the day
when i was younger i looked up to a lot
of these people like you know the yo
guys i looked up to young dog i looked
up to both of them two counts because at
the end of the day review from memphis
it's like who you gonna sign to if you
blow it right now you're gonna sound
double got it that's like the talk and i
looked up to what their motto was how
they did things when i blew up instead
of signing either one i said you know
what i stayed in the past
yeah so now i got my own labels they
inspired you to just
yeah because you stayed indy you could
assign to anybody yeah for real that's
big um what just being from memphis what
did dolph mean to the city like that's a
that's a really serious loss man um
independence most more than anything i
know from my standpoint because this on
my mom teach i'm saying anything anybody
that teach with my mom preaching what i
was brought up on i rocked with so
independence and at the end of the day
family you know i feel like he had he
had like two or three kids he had a he
had a girl i'm saying he's a family
person so when stuff like that happen i
don't even think about the person i
think about the family and the kids you
know that's where it hit home and that's
where he hit most hit 100
um are you are you still in memphis or
yeah i live in memphis but if i'm not in
memphis i'm out here a lot of the time
but i like to create that balance
because there's certain things i want to
implement in my city and i feel like if
i'm out of touch with my surroundings of
the city i won't really know what the
city need right well i mean because some
people in your position might leave
memphis you know a lot of people leave
their hometown maybe go to atlanta just
to kind of get out the way because
usually you got more haters in your
hometown than anywhere else
um so for you it was like a conscious
decision to stick around because you
want to give back to the city and you
want to make sure you kind of have
yeah and just know how to move you know
it's all about how you move when you're
in these places
no
don't never go out of bounds i always
stay in your same routine whatever you
do if you have to go out of bounds don't
do it unless you really have to go
somewhere that you don't go every day
you know
being if you ain't eating if you ain't
at my house if you ain't grab my house
be at home doing what you got to do and
i'm saying getting your piece together
because i can come out here and i can
move around because i know how to work i
work out here but if i'm at home i'm
trying to develop a type of thinking
space or a type of piece so i'm not
really in the mix i feel like being in
the mix this one stuff goes wrong i mean
the inbounds out of bounds there it is
um you were talking earlier that you
feel like you've reached the peak of
your meditation right yeah so what
explain to me um how meditation has been
for you and just like what what is i
don't think people understand like
exactly how to do that
like it's it's you know what i mean like
give us that breakdown and like when you
say you reach the peak of your
meditation what do you you know what are
you alluding to so pretty much like as i
mean okay so when i first started
meditating i was receiving
visions same day i like i like
meditating my eyes would like take like
lights like i could meditate with a
certain type of squint
in my eyes it was crazy he used to be
able to take like certain pictures or
whatever that was in my eyesight and
bring them together and make visions out
of them it was crazy it was like some
[ __ ] i never seen before like one thing
one thing i cannot remember it was some
delivery company i think it was fedex or
something
some damn ups or something i was looking
at it while i was meditating and i think
i broke down the whole letter and it
made like a symbol it was like a eye and
some it was like weird i was breaking
down everything like my third eye was
really moving i would have dreams i have
like strong ass dreams where i'd be able
to feel like i was really there i still
had those dreams but it was more
stronger because it was something i
wasn't accustomed to it wasn't a
lifestyle it was like getting introduced
to it but now it's like i still have
those dreams but i almost don't have
like divisions or certain things like
that but um i feel like i just reached
the peak of
my independence of meditation now i want
to implement certain things like
like tribal with meditations or like
meditating with like a group of people
like certain stuff that can strengthen
what i got going on like mushrooms yo
shrooms too or have you ever heard of
ayahuasca ayahuasca i have heard of that
i haven't gotta go come off a plant huh
yeah you gotta go to costa rica get a
shaman
prepare drink that [ __ ] and then you
know when i heard ayahuasca
i heard of some two here we said is is
is that not where it resets your whole
mind yeah that's what they say ayahuasca
yep they say it's like they're like
i had a friend do do it and he said it
was like 30 years of therapy in like one
day yeah so yeah like [ __ ]
that's pretty that's pretty deep
um yo how are you i feel like you know i
saw the tweet you sent out recently
about how you were saying that
when it comes to music you can't get
nothing right yeah yeah it seemed like
if you were frustrated when you sent
that tweet yeah um
where's your mind stayed at man what was
going through your head when that
happened just just just
what's going on honestly like first
first and foremost it's like it's like
never really a frustration thing to me
it's more so
remember this [ __ ] like just like it's
never like oh man that's right you
weren't down on yourself yeah it's just
it's never there it's more sort of like
i'm gonna show you [ __ ] i can
show you betting i can tell you what i'm
gonna be it i'm saying i'm not gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna let y'all had
a joke so i'm gonna let y'all had a talk
and i'm gonna let y'all have to sign
stuff i'm gonna let y'all do that
but everything come around full circle
[ __ ] gone they gonna block out
them he said that and no people gonna be
on my dick just watch cause like at the
end of the day i look at it like this
people only see a glimpse of what you
really got going they'll never see what
you're doing behind the scenes
i work my ass off like every day i'm
working
hard as [ __ ] like my work ethic is
unmatched and i can i can vouch like
it's unmatched ain't nobody doing what
i'm doing so i know what's mine is
coming to me i know it's already here
it's gonna be this year so i i sent that
i said i'm gonna make sure i get this
tweet out january so when it comes
december 31st they're gonna say goddamn
chop had a hell of a year
it's gonna be fat and they're gonna
remember that tweet
is it hard for you to not pay attention
to outside noise or not pay attention to
like obviously you're on social media
you know i know people some people like
i know that don't they just don't follow
nobody they don't look at the comments
and you know they kind of try to
step step outside of you know maybe just
looking at a lot of [ __ ] yeah i mean
certain outside i know it fuels me it
drives me i use it as motivation as far
as like getting down i get down probably
i get it i get the slightest bit of
questioning like why you know what i'm
saying but
with every why you know
with every question that i say why to um
it's just it's just
it develops some type of drive in my
brain and the body to make me want to
keep going anyway i'm saying so
i feel i just use it as fuel it fuels me
if everybody was if everybody was on my
dig if everybody was good if everybody
was cool what i was doing i'd be relaxed
i'd be you know
if you're doing good this [ __ ] gonna
come so
uh this year man you said you're gonna
have a crazy 2022. obviously the album
is out so go get the album if you're
watching this it's already out um but
what else i mean how are you dropping
just a ton of music this year you got
you know what i'm dropping a ton of
music i'm dropping a ton of gems i'm
doing a lot outside of music what tv
shows movies i'm in them i'm saying
herbs people need herbs come to me
whatever no are you are you hustling the
health are we are we moving some some
herbs in these streets some cmos i've
been doing it last year i um i moved a
lot of herbs i had a website nle health
and wellness you can check it out you
gotta see moss i got herbal viagra i got
herbal viagra yes sir
is that like i think the [ __ ] at the gas
station no it's it's better like the the
rhino pill yeah it's the honey picture
though it's like a powder you know they
say that stuff's natural i don't believe
him you should not naturally visit a gas
station
so you summon this you've tested the
herbal viagra yes sir and it works yes
sir your ladies here it works
so yeah she ain't she ain't felt that at
all you know um
honestly see most of the herbal bag or
two itself really shout out to cmos
anything cmos doesn't do
will it change my oil i'm just playing
i don't even know what you tell me
i mean i'm just i'm just being a dick
but yeah now for real though yes it's a
natural it's pretty much a natural
viagra too so you drink cmos get hard on
pretty nicely
no it's just it helps your endurance in
a bit ah okay okay get hard off of it
but when you when i think of buying
that's what i think of yeah you know sex
enhancer there you know listen there's
this whole wave of [ __ ] talking
about not busting nuts mm-hmm
see my attention semen retention kevin
gates talk about it joey badass talk
about i heard you talk about it
please elaborate no it's good for you um
first and foremost
your your your ejaculation your nut is
is life
so once you give a part of life away
you lose a part of life you know
um i tell everybody this example with
oneness you can run eight miles it's
like the equivalent to eight miles you
know what i mean the miles not many
footsteps it is really
wow one that can make a whole child you
think you can't
you can't you know i'm saying you can't
go the extra mile to do your work or do
extra stuff within that i'm saying so
it's better to keep it in and you'll
feel better like just go on the same
retention like you know how long oh just
try like
how do you have sex i mean often i'm
married my wife's beautiful we'd be
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so like
let's just try i feel like my wife would
be offended if i didn't come no she'd be
like what the [ __ ] and i'd be like no
i'm i ended lee choppa
18 year old kid told me i i i'm too
terrific
do semen retention
so um
okay so is it hard to like
not get your [ __ ] off you got to have a
goal if you put a goal in place if you
be like okay this week
i want to record seven songs
and this is like a song a day you know
if this show go attack it you know what
i'm saying but with you having sex and
busting the honey that's it might not be
possible cuz
let me make it more realistic i'm gonna
speak on my terms like i try to record
three songs a night if i'm if i'm in for
a week if i got a week recording session
i'm trying to do three songs
there's 21 songs in one week that's a
that's an album two albums so now i'm
saying if that's my focus if that's my
approach going into that week i can't
have six because i'm gonna be too tired
it's certain hours that's going to be
knocked off with just each night each
night a certain hour will be knocked off
so um once you develop a goal or focus
something to drive towards i feel like
that's when you implement it you know
so
when you are doing retention semen
retention and then you still [ __ ] right
i'm just trying to understand this i
haven't done it to where i'm [ __ ] and
then like so you'll just be celibate
yeah i'll just be selling okay okay okay
i'm not [ __ ] in i'm like i'm not
sometimes i cuz i'm just wondering if
that's the case when do you know when
it's over no i ain't got the you know
like when you're like all right you're
good because i'm i'm this okay okay okay
okay okay so you just have to you'll
tell wifey that hey look the next week
i'm chilling i got an album to finish
yeah something like that i got uh
a a marathon i'm training for yes that's
why boxers aren't supposed to boxing no
sports well you know they say you can't
you can't [ __ ] before you fight because
it's like it [ __ ] with your endurance
and like tyson did
yeah well tyson also fought on he fought
on [ __ ] dmt and shrooms and weed and
cocaine and
he did that whole last fight with roy
jones junior high as [ __ ] balls
or was it evander
yeah the recent one it was roy jones
no he was he was like yeah yeah he said
he was that yeah
yeah tyson i think
yeah tyson these that's great it's great
yo stop at the interview got to tell you
about our good folks at odd socks man
listen go to odd socks official.com use
the promo code 20 off save 20 off some
of the craziest socks you know they got
the ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
hey question would you um was kind of i
was just talking to uh
d do you know who d smoke is
d smoke he was on netflix rhythm and
flow he won the show and he got
nominated for a grammy last year
um he's a rapper from la
but
we were talking about just the the how
rappers the new bag to get is you could
get a boxing bag go get a pay-per-view
bag would you ever entertain
doing that you know for you know let's
say maybe an undercard on a fight
i don't really have no reason to do that
i feel like you know yeah what if it was
a million dollars
that'd be it recently i mean i don't
really move for money but then but like
i don't know i jump in the ring and get
mine
i really want to fight if i want to
fight somebody yeah
would you like if somebody be like hey i
got a million for you to fight him like
ain't no driving it would have to be
someone you'd actually want to fight
want to knock the [ __ ] out of them
that's fair
i just can't no then there's a lot of
dedication because whatever you got to
train
i'll pass street fights i want to be
able to really you know go the distance
because i get tired of what someone
really had to train i'm gonna have to
take this part of my life off and do
this i ain't really ready for that if i
get older from the front if i don't did
everything i had to do with my herbs did
everything i had to do with my music did
everything i had to do with tv food
truck all this stuff all that stuff is
running well
then yeah but you got a food truck vegan
food truck was it in uh memphis memphis
nice no how was i i mean because the
restaurant industry is obviously a hard
industry to get into right it's hard but
the food truck eliminates a lot of
overhead simpler yeah yeah it's going
well though yeah it's going good i broke
it out like five times i'm trying to get
it i'm trying to get a consistent team
on it to where we can just have it
flowing but this year is gonna happen
he's gonna be real consistent i could
see you doing like uh eventually uh a
nationwide vegan fast food chain what
come on huh yeah for sure that's just
it's just small steps start off like
that so i can learn that master that
then move to like restaurants put some
in the city that's why i want to stay in
the city i want to put like vegan
restaurants i feel like with me just
changing my diet my mind stay tuned so
if a lot of [ __ ] in my city eat vegan
the crime rate might just decrease a
little bit [ __ ] might start thinking a
little differently you might be right i
think vegan people are more peaceful
yeah for so
so i i mean at least all the ones i know
um when's the last time you eat have you
have you slipped up and had any meat
um meat last time i had meat i
accidentally ate some beans with some
crump meat crumbles in it ah
um i was in the airport and i didn't i
didn't know it was beefing there but
like after the third bite i recognized
it would be so your stomach was [ __ ]
up on the plane you weren't like uh
craving wings and we're like [ __ ] it
give me some chicken wings just one time
no i am never i won't be right with
myself i'd be lying to myself
do you miss uh what what do you miss the
most that's the you don't miss any of
them
it's not everything that i eat vegan is
an alternative to what i used to be
accustomed to that's something that
should taste like rubber though man i
don't know no you just got a seasoning
right man some of that some of that fake
those fake chicken nuggets mm-hmm
somebody like the plant-based or [ __ ]
yeah
i stay away from those type it's still
dead stuff is processing it's processing
this is a science experiment so i try to
stay away from
a lot of the
the
i don't know what to call it but it's
like no it's processed food yeah it's
not the real it's not it's just it's
frozen it's boxed up yeah the real [ __ ]
you know i try to have like real natural
[ __ ] i really i'm really trying to move
towards alkaline you know but i feel
like a lot of people not alkaline you
have to have a shelf with you and what
the [ __ ] does that mean alkaline meal is
nothing just really processed it's more
so everything so it's like raw like raw
food and that's just raw but like
everything is it's just ps the ph is
higher than seven couldn't you just
drink a whole lot of ph water but then
like what i'm gonna eat i'm just being
i'm just being ignorant i know y'all
know all right it's like yo let me just
go get a bunch of uh
of us of essentia and that's another
thing watch the spring water the
ascension
and the [ __ ] what's that underwater
it's a little blue one
well the worst water is aquafina and
dasani that should taste like says
brainwater oh dumbass boy
oh uh evian
that's who oh fiji
those three likes watch out for those
like they say it's higher in ph or
alkaline and it's only alkaline because
of the [ __ ] baking soda baking soda
makes water alkaline
so you know how much is this bottle of
water this is it costs a lot it's
bottled in glass no plastic in it to
[ __ ] up the water and the minerals in it
so everything is so like a nine dollar
bottle of water
i don't know i buy about a case oh so
this is like your water no this um just
a story out here i mean but i need to i
need that bro i need an endorsement this
story i push this water oh yeah i'm
surprised you don't have any
endorsements with like some of these
like uh
you know
healthy places no i gotta meet i gotta
meet ceo for sure i push this [ __ ] cause
this all i drink when i'm out here
you don't get a ship to uh to memphis i
tried once and a lot of them busted all
because of the glass yeah but
i try to i pack them in my suitcase real
good when i'm flying back
um yo
that
i know you've already spoken about it
but the incident that happened at the
airport that went viral which is just by
the way some real [ __ ] boy [ __ ] what
happened yeah not on your behalf
obviously
having like some [ __ ] like that happen
does it just make you like like a little
bit paranoid moving around because i
feel like when you're popular not just
you just anybody you're like
anybody can try to go viral off of just
putting you in a [ __ ] stupid
situation
and it's got to be like
i mean i'd be [ __ ] paranoid after
some [ __ ] like that happened no i mean
it's it's a society we living in bro
just gotta embrace it everybody got a
phone
everybody want some type of clout or
whatever
um stuff like that happens so you can
move accordingly and prove what was
wrong why did he get that close it's
just some simple like making sure
security with your 2407. not because you
scared of somebody coming because you're
smart you got a family yeah because like
you know because because what if it what
if it was somebody who was actually what
if somebody what if he had a gun yeah
you know we in the air we was reacting
in the rental car center so you it was
you could have had a gun you know what
if that was the case what if it was
somebody else it was really a threat you
know
so guys just do that to let you know for
this your year you can have one of the
best years of your life you need to have
make sure that you are secure everywhere
you go so that was just he gave me a lot
of little test runs and [ __ ] this whole
month to let me know that this year is
going to be amazing because this this
whole this whole month been hell for me
honestly but he's doing it to to let me
peep all the flaws and in the circle and
everything that's going on so i can
approve it so when it come further down
the line when i'm in september and
something like this was to happen or you
know whatever we'll be ready to handle
it i'm sorry um
you know i know we had talked to
i said blackboard jb was here and i know
we talked before in our interview and
you said he was one of the ogs in
memphis that had kind of [ __ ] with you
early on
is there anybody who's coming up who
you've kind of taken a liking to who
you've maybe given some advice i know i
know you spoke about a conversation you
have with king von right
but i just mean in general like is there
any up and coming artists that you just
are a fan of that maybe you've reached
out to or had some like
some dope conversations with maybe give
us some some game i got three artists on
my label they're from the city um one of
them from arkansas one of them from
mississippi and the other ones from
south memphis but they're all pretty
much from memphis because that's where
they operated so i feel like folktale
draco baby hot and geno two times those
those three right there like they the
faces pretty much was coming cause um
i'm not just saying it because they on
my label i'm saying it because like i
won't put nobody on my [ __ ] label if
you're not talented you know i don't see
no driving you so i i just want to let
y'all know not only is it going to be a
great year for me it's going to be a
great year for nle as a whole
my producer also beats by draco so these
them 4 guys right there
i bet the bank on them i bet everything
on them
that's big
what is what are some what's like some
of the things that you know you you kind
of try to i mean you've experienced this
[ __ ] as a kid
you like how long would you turn 18 no
i'm 19 no you're 19 now
i just turned 19 november 1st both time
flies
jesus i was like 17 when i was with you
when i first came
no i think you were 16 the first time i
interviewed you last year
you might
yeah
no because i interviewed you in like the
first time july of 2020 here yeah yeah
that was 17 and then in 2019 we
interviewed you yeah
damn that's crazy but what what
like
for your artists what do you tell them
like the things to look out for maybe
some advice some [ __ ] that like you you
kind of had to learn the hard way bro
man just just watch how you talk to
people watch how you deal with people
you know you can your emotions can be
feeling one way but try to hide them i
let one of my artists know that the most
because he'd be he'd be going through it
whether his baby mama sister manager
whatever it is just tell him wait wait
wait wait these are different people
right
i just want to make sure that he his
baby mama sister and manager aren't the
same person because that'd be
interesting
well it pretty much is no so his baby
mom and his sister
that's the least of the concern though
but this is not one human okay i'm sorry
it's just it's just a lot of it is the
south i had to ask but continue it's
just a lot of things it's just a lot of
things on i'm saying from different
people you just got to watch out from
you know just know everybody ain't got
your best interest and everybody don't
want to see you
you know fully fully yo reach out full
of potential so just be on the lookout
for it keep your head up stay smooth and
stay out of trouble that's the best
thing you can do as long as you stand
out of trouble you at the way you in the
studio you're doing what's right so what
was the one like was there like a
catalyst to you
changing the way you move maybe changing
like some of your behavior staying the
[ __ ] out the way staying out of trouble
staying out of the [ __ ] [ __ ] like was
there a single like event or something
that had happened or something that you
remember happening where you were like
man i gotta i gotta really chill out man
just watching how the world lives right
now just watching the place where
everybody in i'm saying just taking note
of your surroundings taking notes of
what you're seeing every day i'm saying
that's all i can do i can move according
about like how how i view things you
know or what i feel also just just
personal experiences and just watch
another [ __ ] happen who else on the
album
i got
young thug
i got g herbal
polo g
and
one more
yeah money bag me money bags just
dropped out of single yo i saw that yeah
that's a hell of a hell of a lineup
good it was great
was there anyone who uh
you were trying to get on the album but
maybe because of the deadlines it didn't
work out um smirk it was about the only
person
he was the only person bless me um that
was about it smirk were you in the
studio with these or was it just were
you sending the records out to sending
the records out to them and they was
just knocking them out you know yeah
they got them done on me
2022 man nobody's getting the studio
together yeah hardly ever on me it ain't
working like that we just had blue face
up here and i told him the first time i
ever really uh
thought that he
was improving as a rapper was on that
right on the on the rim he did a remix
with you oh yeah and i was like yo
that song made me be like oh maybe you
aren't a terrible rapper yeah on me um
any more music with blueface coming
because i know you guys would maybe like
there was some sort of flirtation maybe
i'll do some more [ __ ] together like i
mean yeah i mean yeah for sure in the
future
you got to get him on your health [ __ ]
and just get him out of the
just get him off only fans bro
[Laughter]
he's he's turning up on only fans this
[ __ ] is fighting every day and
there's a toothless woman who says she's
pregnant it's it's it's insane
um
anything else man um obviously you're
talking about tv
you said you got tv [ __ ] coming this
year yeah i'm trying to it's in the
works
acting
yep for so
i'm trying over so what tv do you watch
like what's like in your rotation at the
crib
honestly i don't watch tv you don't
watch tv
nothing
don't play video games that's about the
game time so you're playing youtube i'm
on youtube yeah youtube is like my cable
i don't know you don't really need
anything but youtube you get anything
you want on there yeah i mean on netflix
what's your youtube history looking like
oh and at least childhood reaction
videos
i just like to watch people talk about
me see what i can improve what i can't
you say you watch netflix so that's tv
what the [ __ ] you watch on netflix oh
just movies horror movies whatever
someone said the movie no tv series
though no like you don't get into the
episodic shows
the um kevin hart one
oh with wesley snipes it was a good one
was it good mm-hmm i've heard about this
it was real good
never seen ozark
you got to watch ozark
it's on netflix that's just that shit's
crazy yeah some cartel [ __ ] it's pretty
wild well look the album uh out go get
it uh you just dropped it well first of
all
again this is the video's not out yet
technically but when people watch this
there's going to be a video out yeah
shout out proceeds
so which
this video is already uh
shot it and
editing waiting on the coloring they
didn't know
you know what's crazy your videos are
always extremely
fire like there's a few people who
always have just consistent visuals is
that all from your brain are you coming
up with these concepts i direct every
video that's big man nah you're super
hands on like you're like on like bro we
gotta get this [ __ ] colored and most
people wouldn't even most artists ain't
ain't hands-on with their [ __ ] like that
so you got to be you got to be you got a
passion for it you got to well there it
is man i appreciate you pulling up and
um
the cmos i got to tap in gotcha
whatever send me address i'm shooting it
your way there